at 30 minutes into today's space walk
UAE astronaut Sultan al-nayadi has
egressed the hatch the first ever
spacewalk for an astronaut from the
United Arab Emirates
another good look at both of our space
Walkers here on the right you see NASA's
Steve Bowen with red stripes around the
legs of his spacesuit
that'll help you tell the difference
from him and Sultan al-nayadi who's on
the left side in an unmarked suit
as this is his first spacewalk he also
has a little bit of extra time to get
used to maneuvering outside in the
vacuum of space
it's the thermal cover
Ed up
close
copy thermal cover closed you can now
head to esp2 for bags though
and reminder you're going to translate
you can either translate on the wagon
wheel of the airlock across the esp2 or
you can go direct from the toolboxes
over to esp2 to the starboard side
all right it up